now Victoria Saha continues our team
coverage she joins us live near the home
of chasing horse with how neighbors are
reacting to these alleged crimes
Victoria
Vanessa this is a neighborhood with a
few houses in the cul-de-sac and though
the neighbors say they are acquainted
with each other they also tell me the
people living in chasing horse's house
kept themselves
a quiet day for the residents on
Shockwave Court a much different scene
from Tuesday night where police and SWAT
flooded the area to find anything that
connects to actor Nathan chasing horses
crimes this neighbor who didn't want to
be identified and asked us to alter his
voice said there wasn't much
communication with them I never really
talked to only never talk to me God
spoke before they never spoke back so
that was my key not to speak again many
neighbors like him woke up to news that
the man living just Doors Down from them
allegedly was a cult leader had six
wives and is accused of sexually
assaulting young girls I think it's
horrific it was terrible Glenn Perlman
says what he saw in his neighborhood
Tuesday night was a first for him it was
pretty chaotic because everybody was
stopped and I was right near the house
and the police wouldn't let me in he
says he wasn't sure exactly who lived in
chasing horses house because of the
constant foot traffic I think the
renters
because that there's been a lot of
movement in that house on Wednesday I
went to chasing horses home every window
had curtains drawn and there was no
answer at the door
but what I did find odd is that the
exterior ring doorbell camera was
covered with what looked like a medicine
bottle cap making it impossible to
record who was coming and going from the
house
yeah still a lot to uncover in this case
I did speak to many other neighbors who
didn't want to go on camera but Denise
the most common theme here from them is
being in complete shock over all this
reporting in North Las Vegas tonight
Victoria Saha eight news now the